مقطع مؤثر انتشر على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي في العراق عن لقاء شقيقتين
مسنتين بعد فراق طويل حيث استقبلت الحاجه
التركيه وشقيقتها الحاجه نوير بعضهما
بالدموع والاحضان والقبولات يذكر ان
الحاجه تركيه هي اكبر معمره في محافظه
الانبار العراقيه
[موسيقى]
العالي
يعني
[موسيقى]
اظهر مقطع فيديو ظهور تمساح عملاق بحوض
سباحه في منزل بولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه
وطلبت العائله التي تسكن في المنزل
المساعده العاجله من الحياه البريه في
الولايه للامساك بالتمساح الذي يصل طوله
عشره اقدم وذكرت الحياه البريه ان التمساح
تسلل للبركه من فوج فجوه خلف المنزل وكان
يريد فقط الاستمتاع بالسباحه
تداول رواد ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في
السعوديه مقطع فيديو اظهروا دموعه طالبه
تاثر بمفاجاه الاحتفال بتخرجه ولقى
الفيديو تفاعلا واسعا من فرحه الطالب مع
فرحه الطالب وحصد ملايين المشاهدات
[موسيقى]
مشهد خطف قلوب الكثيرين عبر مواقع التواصل
لمجموعه من الشبان في السودان وهم يلعبون
كره القدم تحت دخان كثيف غير مكترثين
باصوات القصف والانفجارات من حولهم في
العاصمه الخرطوم
كوره في العزه
[موسيقى]
قد كاميرات مراقبه خاصه باحدى دور الايتام
مقطع فيديو لسيده تخفي ملامح وجهها تضع
طفله حديثه الولاده امام الدار في مصر
وتفر هاربه مع رجل اخفى ملامحه وجهه
السلطات المصريه فتحت تحقيقا بالحادثه
وارسلتها لدار ايتام للصغار للاعتناء بها
ومنحتها اسم كارما
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات